Best friends, Jeanine Bobenmoyer and Sarah Harker
are in their hometown of Indianapolis.
These moms are dedicated to connecting moms across the city,
and now we're about to connect with them
and their love of Indy.
Watch this.
(upbeat music)
Hi, Drew, I'm Jeanine.
I'm Sarah.
We are so excited to take you around Indianapolis today
to some of our favorite places.
Drew, you're gonna love it.
I cannot wait.
Sorry, did you just say Drew, as in Drew Barrymore?
Uh, yeah.
Wow, hey Drew.
Hey guys.
Hey Drew, It's Ryan and Jillian from Indie Now on Fox 59.
Yeah, we were just going in to work.
What are you guys doing here?
We are going to do a road trip for Drew
and take her to some of our favorite spots
around Indy today.
Awesome.
Oh, that sounds awesome.
Yeah, we're on a tight schedule.
All right, well, yeah.
We totally get it.
Yeah, we're really behind schedule.
We gotta go.
See you guys, have fun.
All right Drew, let's go.
We're at Holiday Park.
It's one of the gems of the Indianapolis park system.
I love the programming at Holiday Park,
including yoga at the ruins,
which is where we are today.
It's a little rainy out.
Thanks a lot, Indianapolis weather,
but I think we'll still get a good class in.
Reach your right arm up.
Take a big stretch.
Welcome to The Garage in downtown Indianapolis.
We are so excited to show you around today.
Drew, you're gonna love The Garage.
It's one of our favorite places to grab something to eat.
So there's a ton of different vendors
that you can choose from.
And it was just recently voted
one of Time Magazine's number one places
to visit in the country.
Don't forget, we've got one more place
that we need to take you.
Any ideas?
Give me a hint.
Okay, ready?
Okay.
Let's go to the Speedway.
You're gonna love the Indianapolis Motor Speedway.
This is one of the biggest and best attractions
in the entire city.
It is where racing happens all year 'round.
Indianapolis is the racing capital of the world.
Drew, we got your flag ready for you on your Camaro.
We're so ready.
Thanks so much for hanging out with us today Drew.
We've had a blast.
We have loved showing you around Indianapolis.
And I think we need to take one last lap.
Here we go.
Yeah.
(woman laughs)
(theme music)